Let's look at these examples ,first let's say you saw a movie with a group of
friends and you weren't sure how you felt about the movie until you were
walking out and your group of friends start talking about how much they love
the movie. And you find yourself liking the movie more and more ,now let's look
at this scenario you walk into a waiting room of an office building and you see
people writing their daily schedules all over the wall with markers so after a
while in the waiting room, you pick up a marker and start writing your weekly
schedule on the wall as well. So is scenario one a normative social influence
or an informational social influence? And same question for scenario two. Write
the corresponding letter in the box for the appropriate type of social
influence.